Trascrizione: Virginia Vittori
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Luciano Marson: Nell'estate del 1987
avevo quasi 34 anni,
la metà di quelli che ho adesso;
e non ero mai stato all'estero,
se non nel 1976, a Montecarlo
con la Cinquecento, la mia prima auto.
Non ero mai andato
a Vienna, Parigi o Londra.
E in quel momento lì,
ho deciso di cambiare passo.
In due settimane ho fatto passaporto,
visto turistico, le valige,
e sono partito per il Giappone.
Lì, per visitare gli antichi templi
lo si doveva fare a piedi nudi.
E il contatto,
l'esperienza del contatto dei miei piedi
con il legno secolare
delle travi inserite nei pavimenti
mi ha trasmesso un'emozione,
un qualcosa che non ho più dimenticato.
Da lì in poi non ho più accettato
che il legno venga bistrattato
con delle vernici chimiche
che lo snaturano.
Ho cominciato a sperimentare
cere, oli vegetali, sapone.
Ho anche osato presentare
dei complementi d'arredo grezzi,
solamente levigati.
Perché volevo che più persone possibili
provassero la gioia
dell'accarezzare o toccare,
sentire il legno nella sua forma naturale,
meglio se caratterizzato
dalla patina del tempo.
Non ho più accettato che esistano -
Vi ho raccontato queste cose
perché fa parte del mio DNA,
è una delle mie caratteristiche
che ho notato che mi appartengono:
l'amore per il legno, per la natura;
e il rifiuto per tutto ciò che è falso,
tutto quello che vuole apparire
quello che non è.
- Karin Friebel: Poi sono arrivata io.
Nel 2006, la ricerca di un materiale
naturale come il legno,
ma innovativo come un legno
che addirittura si cuce,
porta Luciano a scoprire
l'azienda di Alberto.
Alberto è un signore eccezionale
che ha avuto il coraggio
di inseguire un sogno.
Ha solo la quinta elementare,
ma il suo ingegno
e la sua profonda conoscenza,
la sua profonda curiosità,
lo portano a mettere a punto
un processo innovativo
grazie al quale
riesce a rendere malleabile,
e addirittura cucibile e imbottibile,
il tranciato di legno.
Io che ho incontrato Alberto,
e mi sono licenziata in tronco
per accompagnarlo in questo suo sogno,
conosco così Luciano,
l'imprenditore che esce dagli schemi,
che investe in ricerca,
in bellezza e unicità;
e si rifiuta di fare
quello che fanno gli altri.
-LM: Le due aziende, così,
realizzano insieme
dei prodotti eccezionali
che vengono anche esposti in una mostra
alla Triennale di Milano, nel 2007.
Già il titolo, "Surprising Wood"
preannunciava le opere
di ingegno, sorprendenti,
che avremmo trovato lì esposte.
Come questa cintura in legno di gelso -
abbiate pazienza,
ma devo cercare di non far cadere
l'attrezzatura che ho dietro,
che si piega, si può rotolare,
si può annodare ed è anche cucita.
- KF: La vita fa scivolare via,
velocemente, gli anni;
e i tanti viaggi
che adoro fare, fin da bambina,
mi fanno assaporare sempre più bellezza.
Capisco che la bellezza è diversità,
e che la diversità è ricchezza.
E che la natura, i popoli, tutti i paesi
vanno proprio amati e rispettati,
ognuno nella sua diversità.
Ed è per questo che adoro
cambiare meta, ogni anno,
proprio per la ricerca
del bello e del diverso.
Ma c'è un'unica città alla quale
non mi stanco mai di tornare:
Venezia.
Questo luogo è in grado di trasmettermi
un'energia che sento
come una grande medicina,
in grado di alleviare i momenti
anche più bui della mia vita.
Mi aiuta a superare, anche,
la perdita prematura dei miei genitori.
Ed è proprio nel 2011,
quando muore mio padre,
che mi ritrovo ad abbandonare
il mondo del legno, e del design,
per prendere in mano
l'attività di famiglia.
Quello che non abbandono mai, però,
è la ricerca del bello,
l'amore per il bello;
e quindi decido, nel 2016,
di visitare la "Biennale"
di Architettura di Venezia.
Inaspettatamente, Luciano mi telefona
e mi propone di visitarla insieme.
LM: In quei giorni,
la mia vita privata era in rivoluzione,
e cominciava ad esserlo
anche quella professionale.
Ricevo una richiesta di un incarico
da parte di un imprenditore,
un investitore,
che aveva accesso alle "bricole".
Sono quei pali
che sono immersi a gruppi di tre,
nella laguna di Venezia,
per segnalare i canali navigabili
alle imbarcazioni.
Ecco: questo imprenditore
voleva trasformarle in mobili di design,
e voleva che mi incaricassi
di seguire questa impresa.
Io mi sono rifiutato perché -
precisando che esiste già un'azienda
che è leader in questo settore,
che già da anni faceva
questi mobili, queste cose.
Però, questo rifiuto dell'incarico
mi ha fatto scattare alcune riflessioni.
Così ho cominciato a pensare
che le bricole non sono l'unico materiale
che a Venezia viene scartato, cambiato;
che era bello recuperarlo,
però era, sarebbe stato ghettizzante
fare un'azienda con un solo materiale.
E così comincio a pensare che Murano,
con gli scarti dei suoi vetri,
potrebbe essere una miniera inesauribile.
Penso che i vaporetti
cambiano, regolarmente,
le cime con le quali attraccano.
E quindi, comincio a pensare
di recuperare svariati pezzi di Venezia.
Poi penso, anche,
che Venezia è, come tutti sappiamo,
una città amata,
desiderata come meta turistica da tutti.
Però, i turisti che vi arrivano
non trovano un'adeguata
offerta di souvenir
di qualità materica ed estetica
pari alla qualità della città,
che è fantastica.
E quindi penso ai souvenir:
però, mi dico, anche fare
solo souvenir è ghettizzante.
E mi immagino di aggiungere
altri oggetti utili alla persona
da poter vendere,
anche svincolati da Venezia stessa.
Mi immagino, anche,
di incaricare per i progetti,
per il disegno di questi oggetti,
i miei amici designer
che avevo collezionato negli anni.
Rimango molto meravigliato, molto sorpreso
dall'entusiasmo con il quale
questi affermati professionisti,
carichi di impegni di lavoro già di loro,
accettano immediatamente,
e con entusiasmo,
di progettare per una start-up
ancora sconosciuta.
- KF: E io sento parlare,
giorno dopo giorno, Luciano
di questi pezzi che voleva salvare,
trasformandoli in oggetti di design.
E più lui ne parla, più io mi innamoro:
dell'uomo, e dell'idea.
(Applausi)
E io, di Venezia, sono sempre
stata innamorata, fin da piccola;
perché date le mie origini,
mezze tedesche e mezze comasche,
ogni qualvolta arrivavano
i parenti da lontano,
la magia di Venezia era
un dono dovuto da fare loro.
E così si partiva,
per questa città unica al mondo,
per questa bolla sospesa nel tempo.
E lì mi trovo a ritornare
sempre, anno dopo anno:
perché lì respiro bellezza,
che non è solo la magia
che colgono i miei occhi;
ma è, soprattutto,
la sensazione di benessere
che questa città mi lasciava.
Scusatemi, è l'emozione!
(Applausi)
Praticamente, respirare venezianità,
eccellenza, alto artigianato
mi fa star bene;
e di rientro a casa,
vedevo anche i miei problemi
come più piccoli.
Insomma,
sento parlare Luciano del progetto,
lo vedo nascere e prendere forma.
E così, cominciano a brillarmi gli occhi.
Sì, perché Luciano non stava solo parlando
di produrre questi oggetti con un legno,
con un materiale che ambedue
amavamo molto, il legno;
ma di recuperare un legno esausto:
appunto, questo delle vecchie bricole
che avevano vissuto per anni
nella laguna di Venezia.
E mi è sembrato meraviglioso.
Proprio perché potevamo
produrre questi oggetti
senza tagliare gli alberi,
senza così deforestare;
e senza quindi infliggere
un'ulteriore ferita al nostro pianeta.
Così, diciamo, torna -
utilizzando questo legno scarto,
viene donata una seconda vita
a questi oggetti, una seconda chance.
E poi, Luciano aveva conosciuto Gianluca,
presidente della Cooperativa
Sociale Futura:
e stava pensando di affidare
la più parte delle lavorazioni
proprio a questa realtà
che reintegra nel mondo del lavoro
60 ragazzi disagiati.
Ragazzi diversi -
o come preferisco chiamarli io, unici.
Persone con svantaggio sociale o fisico.
E quindi io che appartengo -
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Il mio sostegno!
È una cosa che mi tocca molto
perché io, che appartengo al mondo
di queste persone meno fortunate
per un problema che ho fin dalla nascita,
mi sento toccata nel profondo.
E così, guardo Luciano e gli dico
“Luciano, devi lasciare stare
tutto il resto,
ed è qui che ti devi concentrare”.
- LM: Comincio a pensare al nome
da dare a questa nuova attività:
ed essendo Venezia una città amata
in tutto il mondo, a livello universale,
ho pensato che doveva essere in inglese,
la lingua straniera più conosciuta,
più parlata nel mondo:
e quindi, "I pezzi di Venezia",
che mi aveva inizialmente ispirato,
diventa "Pieces of Venice".
Nasce così una delle prime benefit company
del nordest d'Italia,
sicuramente la prima che si occupa
di sostenibilità e di vivibilità,
di turismo consapevole
che faccia del bene
ai veneziani, ai turisti
e alle persone meno fortunate di noi.
-KF: Parte così la nostra
avventura imprenditoriale,
insieme nella vita e ora anche nel lavoro.
Luciano ed io, però,
non volevamo fare l'ennesima impresa
che guardasse solo al profitto,
ma desideravamo perseguire
l'obiettivo di generare valore
mettendo al centro il benessere, proprio,
di territorio e di persone.
Così creiamo la squadra,
e decidiamo di circondarci
di persone e realtà affini a noi,
con il nostro stesso entusiasmo,
e che volessero perseguire
proprio questa via della sostenibilità.
Nascono così le collaborazioni più felici
con persone e realtà
che ad oggi sostengono il progetto.
La bellezza, così come la intendiamo noi,
volevamo proprio che facesse parte
di questa avventura imprenditoriale;
e questo decidiamo di farlo, proprio,
circondandoci di persone
con i nostri valori nel loro DNA.
Inoltre, questo progetto
ci dava l'occasione
di mettere Venezia al centro
dei nostri interessi,
esplorare la città,
conoscere proprio da vicino
i suoi luoghi, i suoi abitanti.
E così pensiamo, anche,
che questa città straordinaria,
che nasce dalle acque ormai 1600 anni fa,
è permeata di primati, e di eccellenze,
riconosciute in tutto il mondo.
Luoghi pieni di storia, di culture,
di cultura e di arte.
Così decidiamo di raccontarli,
perché per noi la bellezza
era anche condivisione,
e condividere ci rendeva felici.
Decidiamo, così,
che i nomi dei nostri oggetti
dovevano essere sempre
indirizzi di Venezia,
così da spingere gli amanti della città,
o i turisti che acquistavano i prodotti,
a fuoriuscire dai classici percorsi
che tutti quanti noi conosciamo,
tipo Rialto e San Marco,
e andare alla scoperta, proprio,
di una Venezia più autentica.
Volevamo condividere quello che stavamo
vivendo e scoprendo noi:
da vecchie librerie a musei, ristoranti,
antiche farmacie, chiese e dipinti.
Insomma,
volevamo che il nostro fosse, anche,
un progetto di trasmissione culturale.
-LM: Al progetto, però,
mancava ancora qualcosa:
mancava far diventare
l'acquirente parte attiva.
Con Karin incontriamo Nicola,
il presidente della Onlus
"Masegni & Nizioleti",
un'associazione che mette al centro
la cura del territorio della città,
l'essere sempre in ordine;
e questi ragazzi, nel loro tempo,
istituiscono delle giornate di pulizia
e liberano la città dai graffiti -
e dalla plastica, soprattutto.
Ecco che abbiamo trovato
il nostro anello mancante.
Decidiamo così di donare,
a questa associazione,
una parte dei nostri proventi.
Un nostro modo per dire grazie alla città
e restituirle parte del tanto
che ci stava tornando.
- KF: E poi c'erano
i segnali, le coincidenze:
tutto portava a Venezia.
Quando nel 2017 nasce il nostro progetto
avevamo appena acquistato casa:
e sapete dove siamo andati ad abitare?
Nell'abitazione che fu dei discendenti
di un doge veneziano.
Il 67º, per l'esattezza:
il doge Cristoforo Moro.
E così, quando i nostri vicini di casa,
Francesco e Gabriella,
ce lo raccontarono,
e come benvenuto ci regalarono un piatto
con lo stemma dogale della famiglia Moro,
beh, ci vennero i brividi;
E così seguivamo un flusso
di eventi, di incontri;
e tutto quanto ci portava a Venezia.
Un altro incontro fortunato, ad esempio,
è stato quello con Alberto Toso Fei,
che è uno scrittore, saggista
e un profondo conoscitore
proprio di Venezia,
dei suoi misteri,
delle leggende, dei luoghi.
Beh, insomma: Alberto,
quando lo abbiamo contattato,
conosceva già il nostro progetto
e ne era rimasto colpito.
Così è salito a bordo con noi,
pieno di entusiasmo.
E a oggi è il nostro narratore ufficiale
della nostra realtà,
e ci sta aiutando con lo storytelling,
così da rafforzare questo obiettivo,
che avevamo, di trasmissione culturale.
E insomma, seguendo questo percorso
di bellezza, di passione,
sono arrivate tante soddisfazioni:
tra cui anche quella di essere annoverati
tra i "Green Heroes",
gli eroi verdi di Alessandro Gassmann.
Il noto attore e regista,
negli ultimi anni,
è diventato anche un attivista
impegnato nella lotta
contro i cambiamenti climatici.
E quindi, lui ha deciso
di scrivere un libro
perché ha raccolto tante storie
di imprese come la nostra,
che hanno messo al centro
il recupero e il benessere
del territorio e delle persone.
E con questo libro lui racconta
di un'Italia che si impegna:
che non rimane ferma a guardare,
ma con un diverso modo di fare impresa
ci dimostra che le soluzioni
ai tanti problemi ambientali già ci sono.
C'è, ad esempio,
chi mette a punto dei materiali edili
che derivano dallo scarto del riso.
Così si possono costruire
delle case a impatto zero
che non hanno bisogno
né di essere riscaldate,
né di essere raffreddate.
Oppure, c'è chi mette
a punto delle pitture
con lo scarto dello yogurt,
pitture che sono in grado
di assorbire l'inquinamento
e addirittura neutralizzano il CoVid;
aziende agricole che producono
rispettando i tempi della natura,
creando economia circolare
a emissioni zero.
Insomma,
si può avere molta soddisfazione
e anche ritorno economico;
e con tanto entusiasmo,
il libro di Gassmann
questo ce lo dimostra.
Ed è quello che vorremmo anche noi,
oggi che siamo qui su questo palco;
dirvi che insieme si può, si può.
E se tutti insieme
perseguiamo questa strada
di bellezza, di sostenibilità,
di cura per l'ambiente, per le persone,
un mondo migliore è possibile.
Il segreto è di avere
una visione a lungo termine
e non girarci dall'altra parte.
E non coltivare, sempre,
questa cultura dell'indifferenza;
ma iniziare ad agire,
perché insieme si può fare.
-LM: A quanti ci chiedono cosa è,
per noi, la "sostevivibilità",
Karin e io rispondiamo
che è mettere al centro
delle proprie azioni,
anche imprenditoriali,
la cura e il benessere
delle persone e del territorio.
Perché un mondo sostenibile e vivibile,
fatto di bellezza e rispetto,
è possibile.
Concludo con un ricordo che risale al -
ho iniziato parlando dell'87.
Concludo con un ricordo
che risale a due anni prima,
quando un avvocato tedesco mi disse
"Luciano, ricorda: Se vuoi, puoi".
E vista la mia faccia perplessa,
continuò dicendomi:
“Sì, Luciano! Prova a dirmi qualcosa
che hai realmente voluto,
ma non hai potuto fare.
Ma devi realmente averlo voluto”.
Dal 1985, ho cominciato
a fare sogni realizzabili.
-KF: Insomma: se avete un sogno, osate.
Se volete un mondo migliore, impegnatevi.
E se volete essere felici,
fate ciò che vi appassiona
e che vi fa star bene.
E state attenti ai segnali.
Coglieteli e seguite il flusso,
e abbiate anche un po'
di incoscienza nel buttarvi,
anche se tutti quanti dicono
che è da folli.
Fare la cosa che vi appassiona,
e che vi fa star bene,
porta sempre con sé una grande bellezza.
Grazie.
(Applausi)